[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine sache scheint inzwischen so
ausgemacht zu sein wie das amen in der
kirche russland wird im kommenden winter
seine psychospielchen mit drosselung
seiner gaslieferungen bis zum anschlag
aus reisten nur dass der erdgasbedarf
europas aus dieser quelle nicht
gewährleistet werden kann lange schon
geht es bei der suche nach alternativen
zu russischen energie nicht nur darum
den aggressor für die grausame version
in der ukraine zu bestrafen inzwischen
geht es vor allem um die vereitelung des
einsatzes von energie als waffe und
druckmittel gegen die ihnen wie radikal
russland dabei vorgeht sind wir schon
daran wie es nord stream 1 in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten als
politisches instrument eingesetzt hat
ein taktieren das sogar während der
touristen phasen des kalten krieges kauf
vorstellbar war galt selbst die
kommunistische sowjetunion damals als
zuverlässiger gaslieferant für den
kapitalistischen klassenfeind kann man
dies vom total durchgeknallten russland
unserer zeit kein bisschen mehr
behaupten zwar versuchen putins reich
unseren energiekonzern gazprom nach wie
vor formal als vertragskonform
auszusehen aber sehen nutzen jede
erdenkliche spitzfindigkeit aus um die
transportkapazität der pipeline zu
minimieren und den gaspreis dadurch zu
maximieren inzwischen ist daher jedem
klar welches spiel hier wirklich
gespielt wird und worum es ihnen
wirklich geht zwar korrigierte der
gaspreis nach einer erneuten spitze
wieder nach unten da die füllung der
europäischen gas speicher beschlossen
sein dürfte die gaspreise in europa
deutet jedoch darauf hin dass sie die
lage langfristig bis mindestens 2025
nicht normalisieren wird
[Musik]
und je nachdem wie sich russland verhält
und wie hart der winter wird könnte es
kurzfristig noch schlimmer werden der
wintereinbruch und die verringerung der
russischen lieferungen nach europa
lassen einen erbitterten preiskampf
zwischen den asiatischen und
europäischen volkswirtschaften erwarten
jeder wer sich so viel gas wie möglich
sichern erste wirkungen sehen wir ja
schon jetzt zb im neuen gesetz über die
speicher für stände wo es auch heißt
whatever it takes die speicher müssen um
jeden preis gefüllter
intensität des globalen lg wettbewerb
steigt nach erneuter russischer
lieferkürzungen aus diesem grund könnte
der preis für nicht russisches importgas
für europa auch nach einer entspannung
wieder steigen experten erwarten dass
fünf bis zehnfache des üblichen gas
kreises der letzten fünf jahre meine
liegen bisher politik zuschauer da steht
der ölpreise war ein segen förderländer
wie saudi arabien kuwait und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate der
jackpot könnte aber an ein anderes
kleines emirat am persischen golf gehen
die rede ist von qatar
ich habe euch ja schon mehrmals davon
erzählt katar ist im grunde ein koloss
ein gigant unter den produzenten und
exporteuren von erdgas höchste zeit also
das machtvolle emirate näher unter die
lupe zu nehmen meint er nicht auch also
obwohl katar kaum mehr als 11.500
quadratkilometer umfasst und weniger als
drei millionen einwohner zählt ist es
ein knapp 20 prozent marktanteil der
drittgrößte gastmutter der welt und der
zweitgrößte exporteur von verflüssigtem
erdgas genau das liquefied natural gas
kurz lng das dafür sorgen soll dass wir
hier in europa über die nächsten winter
kommen ohne weiter unter dem joch
russlands leben zu müssen um diese
herausragende rolle auf dem gasmarkt zu
erringen wurden in katar große
anstrengungen unternommen
das bild das sie auf dem bildschirm
sehen ist zum beispiel der hafen von ras
laffan er liegt etwa 80 kilometer
nördlich von doha der hauptstadt des
landes hier verflüssigt und von hier
exportiert katar als 70 prozent der fast
128 milliarden kubikmeter gas die das
emirat jedes jahr an den rest der welt
verkauft von hier aus fahren große
tanker vor anzuheben in japan china
südkorea und indien
ihr habt vielleicht noch nie was von ras
laffan gehört aber dieser hafen ist
einer der wichtigsten geostrategischen
punkte auf diesem planeten ein unfall
hier könnte eine der größten
energiekrisen der geschichte auslösen
tatsache ist dass seit dem überfall
russlands auf die ukraine zahlreiche
hochrangige regierungsvertreter aus der
ganzen europäischen union mit einem ganz
bestimmten auftrag nach doha gereist
sind so viel gas wie möglich zu kaufen
nicht zuletzt auch medienwirksamen der
deutsche wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck dazu aber mehr am ende dieses
videos wenn heute wollen wir das alles
wenn die größeren geopolitischen
zusammenhänge einordnen welche uns
verstehen hessen welche auswirkungen
auch für uns zu erwarten sind daher
stellen wir uns folgende frage inwieweit
ist katar hat wirklich wichtig für den
globalen energiemarkt wie viel geld
schafft dieses kleine emirat aus der
gasförderung und warum ist einer der
größten gewinner des ukraine krieges
wenn diesem video werden sie natürlich
all diese fragen beantworten und wie
beginnt man eine solche anforderung
besten richtig mit den üblichen blick in
die geschichte
[Musik]
eine entdeckung die alles veränderte
katies beziehung zum erdgas reicht bis
in die frühen 70er jahre zurück damals
machte der britische ölkonzern shell im
persischen golf einen beeindruckenden
entdeckung gerade an der grenze zwischen
den hoheitsgewässern quartals und des
iran
[Musik]
die rede ist vom sogenannten erzielt das
mit einem umfang von 6000
quadratkilometern das größte erdgasfeld
ist dass sie auf der erde gefunden wurde
es wird geschätzt dass allein das north
field mehr als 15 prozent aller
konventionellen erdgas reserven weltweit
ausmacht die begeisterung damals hielt
sich jedoch noch in grenzen
in den 1970 er jahren hatte gas einen
geringeren wert und erst recht an diesen
ort ökonomisch konnte gab es damals nur
mit hilfe großer preis effektiv verkauft
werden und die nötigen märkte waren weit
weg von katar natürlich weiß bei den
damaligen preis und nicht rentabel eine
pipeline von katar zum beispiel europa
zu bauen die entdeckung war also eher
eine nette randnotiz als eine wichtige
nachricht schon mal der große
energieträger des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts eben doch das leichte
verfügbare apple blieb
was das anging änderten sich die dinge
jedoch bald diametral ende der 1980 er
jahre begann die katarischen behörden zu
erkennen dass ihre erdölreserven zu
klein waren um die zukunft des landes zu
sichern die gasvorräte hingegen würden
deutlich länger halten zumal es sich
abzeichnete dass das ein immer
bedeutenderer energieträger werden würde
das problem bestand nur noch darin dass
gas leicht und relativ kostengünstig zu
transportieren also gesagt getan die
katarische regierung begann erhebliche
summen zu investieren um die entwicklung
der technologien für die verflüssigung
brot anschließende realisierung zu
fördern denn sollen gas nicht per
pipeline transportiert werden so bietet
sich eigentlich nur der seeweg als
alternative an um gas aber per schiff zu
transportieren muss es zunächst in einen
flüssigen zustand überführt werden wofür
es auf minus 161 grad celsius abgekühlt
werden muss um diese technologie
technisch und vor allem wirtschaftlich
tragfähig zu machen hat die katarische
georg massiv wenn die gesamte
produktionskette investiert pipelines
verflüssigungsanlage große methan tanker
speicheranlagen wie der verdampfung
anlagen und so weiter und so fort es
handelte sich um ein riesiges engagement
für forschung entwicklung und vertikale
integration und es funktionierte
fantastisch
[Musik]
im dezember 1996 schickte qatargas die
erste lieferung von verflüssigtem erdgas
nach japan spätestens von da an wuchs
die fördermenge in katar exponentiell an
von kaum zehn milliarden kubikmetern im
jahr 996 ist auf 176 milliarden
kubikmeter im jahr 2015 seit damals
verwalten die fördermengen auf diesem
hohen niveau und so wurde ein
unternehmen gegründet das die geschicke
dieser kleinen dazu verändern und die
welt bei der energiewirtschaft
revolutionieren sollte katar wurde
schnell zu einer der größten erdgas
exporteure der welt und zu einem
wichtigen lieferanten für länder wie
japan südkorea taiwan und china ein
riesiger erfolg in asien der sich in
europa jedoch nicht wiederholen ließ und
warum nun abdullah bin hamad al attijah
der ehemalige energieminister des landes
bringt es auf den punkt
1997 oder 98 reiste ich nach deutschland
traf mich mit deutschen
regierungsvertretern und wir
diskutierten darüber ob katar ein
lieferant werden könnte sie antworteten
wir glauben nicht dass wir eure energie
brauchen weil wir über pipelines viel
mehr gas aus russland bekommen und das
ist billiger damals schon brachte katar
das argument der energiesicherheit und
resilienz auf dem tisch aber die
europäer im allgemeinen und besonders
die deutschen schenken ihnen keine große
beachtung und zwar bis s 5 nach 12 stand
und so liegen die dinge heute natürlich
ganz anders universellen ski selbst
erklärte in seiner rede vor dem doha vor
um das katar eine schlüsselrolle dabei
spielen könnte russland daran zu hindern
energie zur erpressung der welt zu
nutzen aber diese geschichte kennt er ja
schon die frage ist nun wie viel geld
verdient das emirat wirklich mit seinem
gas warum es ausgerechnet katar einer
der großen gewinner des überfalls auf
die ukraine über wie viel gas dass das
kleine land genau und welche
geopolitische bedeutung hat es lasst es
uns sofort herausfinden
viel mehr als ihr euch vorstellen könnt
wie viel gas hat dieses kleine emirat
nun die besondere die zuschauer haltet
euch gut fest denn ende 2020 beliefen
sich die nachgewiesenen reserven katars
auf rund 25 millionen kubikmeter das
sind 13 prozent aller bisher entdeckten
reserven weltweit das dreifache der
reserven ganz lateinamerikas und fast 70
prozent der gesamten erdgas reserven
russlands aber natürlich ist russland
1500 mal größer 150 mal mehr einwohner
und damit köpfe auf die die einnahmen
verteilt werden könnten man hat in katar
also den geologischen jackpot geknackt
doch das ist nicht alles denn die
kataris haben nicht nur jede menge gas
sondern auch die niedrigsten lng förder
und export kosten der welt daher sind
ihre gewinnspannen deutlich höher als
die jeder anderen großen exporteure dass
zum beispiel mal einen blick auf diese
nachricht
sitz hinter juni 2020 asiatische lng
spotpreise durchbrechen 38 dollar pro
million britische wärme einheit da sich
die versorgungsrisiken verschärfen
außerdem zeigt die preiskurve dass der
preis für flüssigerdgas
höchstwahrscheinlich mehrere jahre lang
über 25 us dollar liegen wird und wisst
ihr wie hoch die kosten für förderung
und export für tag sind nun es sind nur
knapp vier dollar das sind
kostenstrukturen und margen von denen
anderer wirklich nur träumen können
katar exportiert derzeit jährlich etwa
110 milliarden kubikmeter gas das
bedeutet dass das emirat im jahr 2022
mehr als 100 milliarden dollar mit
seinem gasverkauf verdienen könnte
obwohl ein großverein export an
langfristige verträge gebunden ist sehr
viel geld für ein so kleines land also
und die frage ist was katar wohl mit all
diesen geld machen wird nun ein großer
teil davon wird dazu verwendet den
ohnehin schon gigantische staatsfonds
weiter zu mästen ein fonds mit denen die
regierung in doha rund 450 milliarden
dollar in unternehmen immobilien und
projekte auf der ganzen welt investiert
hat nicht zuletzt auch in deutschland
bei der relativ kleinen einwohnerzahl
kattas bedeutet ein investitionsvolumen
von 450 milliarden dollar circa 160
tausend dollar pro kopf da jedoch mehr
als 80 prozent der katarischen
bevölkerung aus einwanderern mit
befristeten aufenthalt besteht liegt das
von der regierung angehäufte pro kopf
vermögen bei rund 1,3 millionen dollar
wenn nur katarische staatsangehörige
gezählt werden
1.300.000 us-dollar pro nase nicht
schlecht was zumal bei der aktuellen
lage da bald noch einiges dazukommen
könnte man könnte fast sagen dass die
katarische regierung kurz davor ist
jedes finanzielle freiheit für all ihre
bürger zu erreichen von der immer
überall geschwärmt wird wollte ich meine
echte finanzielle freiheit nicht die ag
einigen von euch auch in der werbung für
unseren videos manchmal angepriesen wird
ihr wisst ja dass wir darauf keinerlei
einfluss haben also klickt diese werbung
am besten kurz an dann bekommt ihr einen
kleinen obolus quasi als kostenlose
spende und dann schließt sie am besten
schnell wieder so seid ihr dann auf der
sicheren seite
aber zurück an den persischen golf der
jahreshaushalt der regierung in doha
beläuft sich auf etwa 55 milliarden
dollar legt man nun zb den historischen
return des norwegischen staatsfonds und
dessen investitionsvolumen zugrunde
könnte die katarische regierung ihren
gesamten jahres haushalt allein aus der
von renditen bezahlen ganz abgesehen
davon dass die öl- und gaseinnahmen
weiter sprudeln würden man ist da also
schon nicht mehr so weit weg von der
echten finanziellen freiheit
vor allem wenn man die enorme summen
berücksichtigt die sie in den nächsten
jahren noch verdienen werden und wartet
denn wir sind noch nicht fertig wir
haben noch nicht einmal den
entscheidenden punkt genannt
katar energie das nationale energie
unternehmen investiert derzeit mehr als
30 milliarden dollar um seine gasexporte
bis 2027 um 60 prozent zu steigern
zusätzlich investiert man weitere 19
milliarden dollar und die flotte von 70
lng tanker mit 109 schiffen zu erweitern
damit noch mehr gas weltweit verkauft
werden kann wir sprechen hier also von
waren mega investitionen noch vor kurzem
hielten viele experten einen solchen
investitions und fahren für schwer
rentabel weil das land einfach keinen
markt für eine so große menge gas finden
würde wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
die situation jetzt aber völlig anders
katar wird nicht nur diese riesigen
gasmengen auf abgesicherte weise weil
durch langfristige verträge gebunden los
sondern erwägt sogar eine weitere
expansion zu starten denn im moment
strömen die gesuche um neue verträge
buchstäblich von allen seiten herbei
wichtig ist hierbei das wörtchen
langfristig denn derart gewaltige
investitionen müssen sich über einen
langen zeitraum amortisieren doha ist
also nicht an kurzfristigen dies
interessiert dadurch würden sich nur
selbst schaden tatsächlich deutet alles
darauf hin dass mindestens die hälfte
neuen kapazitäten nach europa gehen wird
ein relativ neuer und nach dem bau
weiterer infrastruktur gute skalierbare
markt für katholisches gas
zwanzigster märz 2022 deutschland
schließt langfristigen gasdeal mit katja
aber ausgerechnet die deutsch katarische
gas partnerschaft wie der deutsche
wirtschaftsminister harbeck nach seinem
blitzbesuch in katar im früher als
großen durchbruch verkündete entpuppte
sich im sommer als große luftnummer denn
die kataris hatten weder konkrete
gasmengen für deutschland zugesagt noch
preise vereinbart und bei der
aushandlung verträge zwischen den
betroffenen unternehmen spielte katar
seine marktmacht voll aus es ist sich
schlicht zu schade dafür nur als brücken
lieferant für eine ausländische
regierung zu dienen die sowieso eine
energiewende weg von fossilen
energieträgern plant es bleibt seinen
prinzipien treu und will nur
langzeitverträge eingehen und zwar für
ordentlichen preisen berlin erhielt aus
doha daher lässt sich eine absage und in
deutschland heißt es jetzt aus katar
kommt kein gas ich hoffe ihr versteht
ist wieso angesichts sowohl der historie
deutschlands als handelspartner als auf
der entsprechenden focus perspektiven
die kataris eben kein so großes
interesse mehr haben eher zu helfen mit
anderen worten dann russlands krieg
findet katar mehr als genug die bessere
und verlässlichere abnehmer um
langfristig gigantische mengen einfach
flüssig erdgas zu verkaufen und damit
sprechen wir von hunderten und aber
hunderten von milliarden zusätzlicher
dollar die bald nach doha fließen werden
es wird eine unglaubliche chance karten
wird eine der wichtigsten gasexporteur
sein und seinen markt wird
wahrscheinlich noch jahrelang sehr stark
sein kerken analystin amelies diskutiert
das bringt sie nicht nur dem status als
größter rentier der weltwirtschaft mehr
sondern verleiht der regierung auch
enormen einfluss weltweit noch mehr als
sie ohnehin schon hat
[Musik]
denn es erscheint ja erstaunlich
angesichts seiner größe aber in den
letzten jahren ist dieses land das die
größte us militärbasis im nahen osten
oder eine der größten der betfair werk
nicht nur ein einflussreicher akteur in
sachen energie sondern auch in der
geopolitik geworden
zwanzigster märz 2022 katar vermitteln
zwischen den iran und den usa bei
atomgesprächen der golfstaat vermittelt
auf washingtons und teherans da die
verhandlungen eine entscheidende phase
erreichen wenn washington brüssel oder
ein anderer westlicher akteure zum
beispiel mit den taliban sprechen wollen
ist dh der richtige ort dafür wenn man
mit dem iran sprechen will ist die
ebenfalls der richtige ort und wenn es
darum geht mit der hamas der syrischen
opposition oder mit muslimbrüdern
kontakt aufzunehmen ebenso
[Musik]
und es ist nicht abzusehen dass dieser
einfluss perspektivisch kleiner werden
sollte ganz im gegenteil geld bedeutet
macht und viel geld viel macht durch die
massiven auslandsinvestitionen kann
katar nicht unerheblichen einfluss auf
die länder und unternehmen aus lügen die
um beteiligungen bohlen zumal man weiß
solchen investitionsvolumina auch großen
einfluss auf den erfolg von investitions
richtlinien und vorstellungen guten und
moralischen wirtschaftens bei den
unternehmen hat laut ägyptischen
regierungsvertretern plant katar fünf
milliarden dollar in ägypten zu
investieren als neues versprechen vom
golf der katarische staatsfonds wird bei
den deal eine schlüsselrolle spielen
nebenbei bemerkt wo es präsident joe
biden erließ im märz 2022 eine direktive
mit der qatar den status eines wichtigen
nicht nato-verbündeten verliehen wurde
das ist die gleiche kategorie wie auch
länder wie israel australien und
südkorea haben diese kategorie
ermöglicht es den kataris unter anderem
hochmoderne us-waffen viel leichter zu
ärgern die beiden regierung möchte doha
auf diese weise den beitritt zu einer
von israel angeführten militärbündnis
den nahen osten schmackhaft machen ein
thema über das er erst vor kurzem ein
eigenes video gedreht haben ein
wichtiger faktor bei dieser entscheidung
war natürlich die neue rolle katars auf
die globalen erdgasmarkt ein markt auf
dem der wettbewerb in den kommenden
jahren stark zunehmen wird da länder wie
die vereinigten staaten und australien
links und rechts kräftig mit exportieren
und verdienen wollen dieser wettbewerb
dürfte aber nichts daran ändern dass der
russische krieg in der ukraine die
katarischen gaseinnahmen weiter kräftig
zum sprudeln bringen wird dieses land
ist zweifellos einer der größten
nutznießer der neuen geopolitischen lage
ich hoffe daher dass er die
zusammenhänge und besser versteht und
habe selbst noch folgende fragen an euch
was meint ihr wie katar die gigantischen
geldsumme aus den gaseinnahmen verbänden
wird seht euch doch hierzu vielleicht
noch unser video zur katarische
türkischen geopolitischen agenda an dass
ich euch verlinken werdet wie weit wird
der neu gewonnene einfluss des emirats
erreichen und welche anderen länder
werden eure meinung nach folgt dienst
krieg und in sanktionen gegen russland
profitieren wie immer sind auf eure
angeregte diskussionen zu diesem
kontroversen thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und erst recht etwas
dabei gelernt habt das jahr gibt es mit
einem leisen und freuen und vergesst
nicht das abo mit glücklichem keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich wollen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit ihr
unterhält dieses projekt und dazu führen
in peking besucht findet ihr der
beschreibung im video was gut und bis
bald
[Musik]